mm-hmm thank you good morning let's try
this again the time being just after 10
on June 28th I'm calling to order the
Judiciary subcommittee on house bills
314 and Senate bill 255.
although we have two bills
um that will be before this committee
um
the relationship between the two bills
isn't completely parallel and so I think
we should pursue one bill at a time
unless anyone has any other feeling and
um taking the house bill first
I would suggest that we begin with house
bill 314.
relative to the expectation of privacy
in the collection and use of personal
information
the reason this bill is in the
subcommittee is that the members of the
committee felt that it was very
important
it was uh addressing a timely issue
but as important as it is that is how
complex the issue is and that we needed
more time to be able to
um
delve into
what was necessary
for uh and helpful for us to do now and
what really isn't appropriate
for us a state as against uh the
national government
um
when we last looked at the bill uh of
course we had a lot of testimony and we
also had at least one Amendment
uh
but where today just going to try to get
a sense of where we want to go we would
be meeting today and then we will not be
meeting again until September uh
following house rules uh
but that does mean that if we identify
areas where we want to delve deeper that
gives us time uh for the members of the
committee and for the members of the
public who are interested to help gather
additional information
so that
um I think is all that I need to say to
open the discussion
um
uh chairman Lynn do you have anything
you want to add
um no I I well I do have just a couple
of things and I I guess what I would say
is um I I agree with you your initial
remark that the
the overlap
the the relationship between 255 and 314
is is it it certainly doesn't sort of
neatly fit together I agree with that
um
but what what I had
um been been hoping uh that we might do
and I'm not really
it's not clear to me that it's possible
to do this but I wonder if it would be
worth
seeing if
uh because 255 is dealing with
deal deals with the Privacy issue with
regard to private businesses basically
and and 314
um
particularly if we amended it in a way
that that said
applies to private businesses only to
the only and so far as 250 in other
words it reference 255 by three in 314
to say that
314 applies to private businesses only
insofar as it uh through as 255 covers
private businesses and then
uh the other part of 314 we're dealing
with governmental entities
um
that would be an expansion of of uh 255
which would apply only to governmental
entities and and for for example one of
the big differences there would be that
314 does create a private right of
action against governmental against the
government
um and so I don't know
whether it would be possible to do that
or not and one of the things that I
think would be
would I would think would be very
helpful in that regard is
it's clear that that the that the draft
that the people who brought us 255
spec I mean the the you know sort of the
experts from around the country spent a
lot of time on it and and did you know
it did a very good job in my view of of
their Drafting and I'm wondering if if
uh
we might be able to uh
engage some of those people to take a
look at 314 and see if that melding of
314 and the way I describe could be done
in a in an effective way because one one
of the problems that I see with 314 now
is the the way it's worded it's it it
says in
a section
507 H2 Roman numeral two
no governmental entity shall acquire
collect retain or use any personal
information of any individual residing
in New Hampshire
um where are you in in that oh I'm sorry
it's on page uh page one of the bill and
I'm I'm line uh 24.
uh it says no government entity shall
acquire collect retain or use any
personal information of any individual
residing in New Hampshire from any third
party provider
and so that's just a that's sort of a
blanket statement it would be I mean if
you just if you if you ended your
consideration right there you'd you'd
basically say no no government entity
could ever have any private information
acquired from a third party
which would be really I mean that would
be kind of crazy but then if you go on
to if you go on to the to section three
you see that it there's a huge a number
of exceptions so effectively
subsects the way it's it's drafted
subsection two kind of says Thou shalt
not
accept
in these in the areas covered by
subsection three which is huge I mean
just just for example read
3A
um it says some some paragraph two
though the the broad prohibition doesn't
apply to personal information acquired
collected retained or used by any state
regulatory or administrative agency when
such acquisition collection retention or
uses within the agency's regulatory
investigative adjudicatory or
administrative function well
on its face that would seem to I mean
you know except for situations where a
regulatory agency or some agency of
government was acting in bad faith
um except for that you'd almost think
that almost everything would be accepted
because if uh if an agency if an agency
collects information that they have some
reasonable basis that they think they
think is necessary to do their job
presumably that would fall within that
unlike 255 I think
314 may be drafted in a way that is just
it try it oversimplifies and that may
mean that it would take
a considerable amount of work to make it
fit in and that's why I was kind of
wondering if some of the people who are
who have had some expertise in this area
might uh might be willing to take a stab
at trying to make it fitted
because for example
um collects the information necessary
um what if the department of motor
vehicles
um
honoring the fact that we live in a
capitalist system decide that they want
to sell all that information
um
with that regard to existing law
isn't that an example of or is that an
example of how a regulatory agency might
you know thinking for the best of
reasons
um
I utilize
this information in a way that really
isn't Central to their regulatory
investigative
adjudicatory or administrative function
and there are other examples I mean I
just sure sure no I agree with you I
think that's I think that's right so and
I think we do see that we see that with
the 911 system
um where the information is collected
for a very specific reason
but
um there other agencies want to get a
crack at that information also
the basic problem I think is a you know
is is real it's not it's not imaginary
or you know
um
or just creative things yeah no I know I
agree with you I agree and I think I
that's why I think 314 really is
important uh it's just uh they
I would I would like it if I mean it
would may it would seem to me it would
make sense if we could do it to have a
sort of comprehensive privacy
um bill that that applied both to
private and private Enterprise and to
the government and to the government I
hear that now and just at the
introductory level anybody else on the
committee have something to say
representative Alexander thank you madam
chair
um I remember we were on a subcommittee
about this bill last term
um the the one you have a very long
memory very long memory so the the thing
I like about 314 is it concerns
government entity and I think if we're
gonna start with regulating it should
start with ourselves in my opinion and
then what I like about 255 is that it is
like more it it's very specific and very
like um there's strong definitions so I
don't know how we can
work that through to make it so maybe
if we start with government entity and
then see if it works and then expand it
to non-government entities
um if that works I mean
why can't we just have a law that says
you can't share personal information
that's it right like I don't
do we have to go WIC in specific or can
we kind of just stay wrong one of the
problems representative Alexander is
that you make it if you make it too
simple then what would the legislature
yeah thanks
um
just looking at 314
I think it's interesting that the Clause
above the one that representative Lynn
just pointed out
um
the first thing that it states is really
Broad and it just says individuals shall
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
and personal information including
content and usage given or available to
any third party
um
providers of information and services
not available to the public so that's on
line 21. so it starts off with this very
broad statement about what 314 is doing
and then it's not really until all the
way toward the bottom of the bill online
26 that it says action against a
non-government entity shall not wait
where do you see that online 26. page
two line 26
um 507
yeah so it doesn't really seem it I know
we've thought about this as a
government only Bill but it seems to
only basically carve itself out as a
government-only bill down at the very
bottom and so I don't know if that sort
of lends itself to merging in with the
other
um concept because the other concept
taking care of all those other entities
um essentially one's leaving one out
this one's leaving the other group out
and
um just the way this is put together
seems really confusing because it starts
out
not really specifically talking about
government entities then it starts
carving out a whole bunch of uh
exceptions and then only at the very end
does it basically clarify that it
doesn't create an action against a
government entity so I don't know if
there's any knowledge about why it's
structured that way or if it has to be
well you know oh I'm sorry I I just I'm
sure of course if I if I may you know I
was gonna say I I you raise your that's
that's an excellent point and that is a
point
um that was that was what I attempted
to um to deal with in the amendment that
I had but and you'll see that what the
amendment
what the what my proposed amendments is
to to uh
to uh uh to 314 amendments
yes right and what that was attempted to
do is to
um amend
uh 507 H2 Roman numeral one that starts
on line 21.
um so that it would say
the um
their reasonable expectation of privacy
uh applies
to uh
information given uh or available to a
third-party Pro I'm sorry
I better read an individual should have
a reasonable expectation of privacy and
personal information including content
and usage given or available to
third-party providers of information and
services I I took out the the word and
so providers of third party of
Information Services comma not available
to the public comma and then the
important thing is I added the words and
provided to a governmental entity so
that and I I know I had a I had a long
discussion with representative erf about
this I think he disagreed with that
limitation but my my purpose in having
that limitation was to say to make to
make that this section sort of congruous
with the cause of action section so that
it was
the the expectation of privacy
was was only when the when the
information that's in private hands gets
into the hands of the government then it
becomes private and I and I guess what I
would say is
if we were gonna you know combine 255
and 314 in some fashion
that Roman numeral one
of section H2 where it's sex where it
says except as otherwise provided in law
I mean if we adopted 255 that could be
the the other law that would apply you
know to the private
uh to the private sector information
thank you
no no no no no problem
um does anyone else on the committee
have any introductory comments that they
want to make
um
seeing the uh
uh representative the prime sponsors of
314 are representative Earth and
representative Lynn
um representative erf is here and um
if I'm not
incorrect he's here also with a
colleague from his district who's a
former representative and that's
um uh former chairman Neil Kirk and if
it's all right with the committee I
would suggest that
the monsieurs Earth and Kirk come up and
help us start our conversation here
about 314 including how it may or may
not relate to 255 is are you willing to
good
well you know when you build a building
with
lots of different pieces first you have
to figure out
we have to figure out two things what
you want to build and what the pieces
are that you have available to build
with and that's our
you know it's like Robert Frost when you
build a wall you have to figure out what
you're Walling in and Walling out
um
so
um representative Kirk chairman Kirk
Mr Kirk
thank you madam chairman Neil Kirk from
where
I'm very pleased to be here and I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
you
um
there is a connection between the two
bills but it's tenuous
um
255 deals with large private companies
which collect information about
individuals through a variety of ways
and provides opportunities for
individuals to uh
opt out of the company using that
information for a variety of purposes
Deals Only with information that comes
from third-party providers it's a very
limited subset of the information that's
out in the world
so
the only information that is covered by
314 is information in the hands of a
telephone company or Social Service
Media or a financial institution or
something like that where there is a
business relationship between the
individual and that company
so the individual decides he wants
telephone service provides information
to Verizon Verizon is now a third party
provider of information and services not
Goods Goods is covered by 255 but not
314.
and then the question is to what extent
can Verizon use that information
for other purposes other than to provide
the services for which the individual
arranged a relationship
under U.S Supreme Court decisions there
are no limitations that information
under their third party Doctrine is the
property of Verizon in effect and they
can do what they want with it you have
no expectation of privacy in that
information the purpose of 314 is to
change that it's to say that when an
individual gives his information to one
of these third-party providers of goods
and services
that provider can only use that
information to service the individual
whose account was established they do
not have the right to use that
information for other purposes
okay if
a state agency wants to get that
information or a private sector
individual wants to get that information
they have to go through a process
they can't just get it by asking under
current law
if the police want information from
Verizon about Neil Kirk they can either
call them up directly and say hi would
you give it to me or if that's not the
way Verizon operates they can get a
subpoena which is not based on probable
cause just a subpoena and then Verizon
while it could fight it would not and
they would get the information if this
spill were to be passed the police would
have to get a search warrant based on
probable cause if they wanted to get
that information and they would have to
do it on an individual basis the police
for example today could collect
wholesale information about everybody in
New Hampshire and create a database if
they wish to do so they don't but if
they wish to they could
If This Were to pass they could not do
that except on an individual basis based
on probable cause so the focus of 314 is
very different from the focus of 255.
there is a connection as representative
Lynn has pointed out I'm not sure it's
worth merging the two to deal with that
connection but there is a relationship
um
Representatives Lynn's Amendment would
basically eliminate
the part of this bill that deals with
individuals because this bill really has
two parts to it one the government
restriction part that's h two two line
uh 24 and then the individual part the
private sector part which is h21 line
21.
If you eliminate section one and
representative Lynn's Amendment
effectively did you kept the language
but by adding the words at the end about
a government you basically eliminated
um the the right of of Neil Kirk is an
individual to tell Verizon not to give
his information to somebody
um so that's the effect of your
Amendment uh it would only apply to
government and you're right again
representative Lynn the substantial list
of exceptions was designed after meeting
representative and I with many
government agencies was designed to say
look whatever the agency is doing
currently it should be allowed to
continue that's the practice
so this has a a significant impact
representative Smith's example is one
but it would it would apply to the
police which is why they oppose this
because it would require them to get a
warrant a search warrant rather than
simply a subpoena to get information
from these folks if they wanted to do
that
um
I hope representative Lynn might rethink
his objection to having the private
individual have the same protection
um that is provided in this bill I think
that's very important but I understand
his position and if that were the to be
the wish of the committee it's still
worth passing the bill because what
we've done is basically to say we're
keeping the situation that currently
exists in existence and if in the future
the legislature thinks that the
insurance department or the health and
human services department should not be
able to access
these third-party providers to get
information about Neil Kirk then the
legislature could make a separate
determination in each of those cases
the other thing that's important about
this bill and indeed to some extent
about 255 is that it deals with the new
constitution well not really 255 I
shouldn't say that 314 deals with the
new constitutional privacy provision
which is very Broad in terms of
protecting personal information from
government intrusion
um
so this would be the first legislative
statement about its concept of what that
Amendment means it's saying that
government agencies in certain ways May
and certain ways may not access personal
information
um
I'd be willing to um
work with representative Lynn or the
committee or produce any kinds of
amendments that you want if you
have a policy position on what you want
this bill to accomplish
and it can be made to accomplish many
things but the concern that this bill
addresses to repeat
is information that you voluntarily give
to an organization that's providing you
information or services this does not
apply to Goods
this does not apply to anything you buy
in stores
it's just where you the individual have
a relationship with a provider of goods
and services defined in the bill
and want to maintain the privacy of that
information and not have the provider
use that information for its own
purposes to sell it to make it available
to other private sector organizations to
make it available to government I think
that's a very important privacy
protection for the citizens of New
Hampshire
when I give information to the telephone
company I don't want them revealing it
to Microsoft
none of Microsoft's business the
relationship that I have with the phone
company
and I'm very pleased if police in order
to get that information would have to
get a search warrant I mean if they
wanted to get that information from my
that my house they'd have to get a
search warrant
uh
anyway
um as you know I'm passionate about
privacy so uh you'll you'll you'll
deduct whatever points are necessary for
my passion to make a reasonable decision
thank you madam chairman thank you um
representative or if you have anything
I think he covered it pretty well
thank you
committee have any
questions that they would like to ask
the witnesses a representative tour
yeah just just one question along the
way you had said that the Supreme Court
had eliminated
um this provision or something along
these lines previously was that
unconstitutional grounds or what was the
what was the reason that the Supreme
Court found that the
that the
um
existing law and sorry if I'm not
stating that prep perfectly couldn't
exist
representative Lynn is better qualified
than I am to answer that question but
basically the U.S Supreme Court said the
Constitution did not protect that under
any concept of privacy that was their
interpretation of the U.S Constitution
and
our state supreme court
I think generally has followed that with
certain exceptions for example there's a
very famous case where our Supreme Court
said you have a constitutional right to
privacy uh with respect to
garbage that you throw out in a black
plastic bag on your front lawn so to
speak when that's picked up and taken to
the dump by the garbage people however
it's done
you have not given up your expectation
of privacy in that and the police if
they want to search it would have to get
a warrant
but in New Hampshire there is no
constitutional or legislative
privacy protection with respect to
third-party provider information that
you've given to it now clearly somebody
could bring a legal case and claim that
under the new Constitutional Amendment
that indeed is protected information
the situation hasn't Arisen yet and I
would hope that the legislature in light
of the amendment would adopt this bill
and others like it to Define what kind
of information government has remember
the Constitutional Amendment only
applies to government it doesn't apply
to the private sector it limits
government's acquisition of information
about its citizens I would have liked it
to apply to the private sector but
that's not the way the amendment went
just a quick follow-up yes of course
so that Supreme Court decision in if I'm
understanding what you're saying it
basically said the right does not exist
the right to privacy over date it does
not exist in the Constitution but it
didn't prohibit something like this from
being added which would establish it
we gather information and have a sense
of where where we want to go from here
and benefit of course from the thinking
of people who are
um
following these issues is there anyone
here
um in the uh
in the room who would like to comment
um on
help advise and guide us as to where we
should go
yes
good morning representative good morning
representative Tim McGee one of the
yeah okay
sorry I haven't seen you before seems
that every time that we have one of
these hearings I'm either
at a healthcare conference
like the one week of the session that uh
was at the
and I'm going to tell you a little bit
about it so please indulge me if you
don't mind this is going to be a little
bit of testimony that probably uh would
have helped but we had a lot of esteemed
co-sponsors and knowledgeable folks
testifying so some of my original
testimony might have been redundant
but as this bill has taken shape
um I'll throw in a couple of couple of
cents so my first two terms were spent
on Commerce in 1996 to 2000.
and back then I think one of the things
that I ran on was the right to privacy
and as you know that predated our
Amendment and representative Kirk was
chairman of Finance I believe then right
and we had a common interest in the
right to privacy then
as I do now and I was entering uh
Healthcare as a medical device
commercialization guy and HIPAA was new
and nobody knew what it meant we all
thought it would protect our privacy but
everybody ignored the second p in HIPAA
does everybody here know what that that
second P stands for the portability
that means that your data is incredibly
portable so you go to one Pharmacy and
they know that five minutes earlier you
were at the last Pharmacy
well fast forward 22 years and
was watching the Super Bowl last last
year during covid and I'm kind of a
gadget guy I've developed a few apps
I've got nine patents in cardiovascular
devices and once I stumped Apple
they um they wrote back and said we
don't know what to do with your app
we've never seen anything like it it was
the best compliment I'd ever had
the Super Bowl commercial had a device
on it during covid called The Q Health
device cue and if you're not familiar
with it you should all get one I have no
interest in the company
but it was revolutionary it was a tiny
little box about this big maybe three by
two inches and it's a diagnostic device
and I should tell you that I am chief
commercial officer for a publicly traded
medical device company a Diagnostics
device company
not this one I wish so this little
device Q Health aims to be in
everybody's house if for every every
consumer to help diagnose a whole host
of elements their first was covid
and I immediately ordered this
subscription device because it was going
to provide me with the ability to travel
back and forth across the border to my
company headquarters in Toronto and at
the time you needed a certain type of
approved covid test you couldn't just
have the little free government lateral
flow test or the one you could buy from
the drugstore you needed the higher
level PCR test so do you remember when
there's all the different types you know
certain were approved for airline travel
well this one would allow you to do it
in your house with a video Proctor
anyhow the point of this is there's
those big long Eula agreements end user
licensing agreements that everybody just
Scrolls through some of them don't even
make you scroll through it until the
green acceptor submit bar shows up and
you've probably had this question and
testimony how many of you actually read
those right the answer is nobody at
least no consumer reads those Justice
Lynn reads them and then writes back to
them and asks for a new copy and sends a
red line with track changes right right
he and I are the only ones that ever do
that and then our accounts get canceled
no just kidding but if you want to use
those apps or those devices or
if you're a business that wants the
consumer
to buy those devices and that's the
focus I want you I want to bring to this
discussion if you're a business like
mine or like Q health or one of the
zillions of other you know Venture
Capital funded or private Equity funded
businesses that's trying to make a go of
it and there's thousands and thousands
of these businesses many of them trying
to come to New Hampshire
and I'm actually trying to move my
company to New Hampshire here in the
midst of a bit of a restructuring
um
they need this what's that I'm sure the
government
he just might he just might he just
might we enjoy a nice relationship so if
I'm one of those businesses and and when
I was asked to co-sponsor this
and I spoke with some of the interested
parties like Microsoft you know happily
signed on I said as long as it's
reasonably close to Connecticut and
nothing like California
and when I look at this chart and I see
how many X's we have on here I think
well that's a state that I'd like to do
business in
because that's a state where my
consumers My Consumer customers where it
will be easier to be not just a B2B
business to business
manufacturer and distributor but also a
business to Consumer and what were you
holding up there oh this is the uh the
the tracker that shows what states have
done what uh and
okay and which bills contain right to
access right to correct and right to
delete that's what resonates
even at the the town committee level if
you're giving a legislative update to
your local committee
you can tell them hey I worked on your
right to privacy they get that but did
you know you don't have the right to
delete yourself
and that rings a bell I mean how
exciting is that to deliver that to your
constituents in some fashion the right
to electronically delete yourself
nobody believes that that's even even a
possibility it's the number three when
you turn that turn it sideways and you
go down here and New Hampshire
is maybe the only state or one of the
very few states where the pending
all the boxes and someone behind me will
Private Ryan
well private right yeah yes thanks for
bringing that one up minus on x minus on
AI yes
um don't get me started on chat GPT if
you don't know what it is you should you
um but sure I think though those are two
things that maybe are better left for
the next
um
the next session like representative
Kirk mentioned uh happy to give you my
opinion on it
um I think you've probably had a lot of
discussion on private right of action
already
and um maybe best left for for the next
one what what you have as representative
Lynn as amended I think is a pretty good
step and would it's personally widely
supported
my in terms of full disclosure our
particular business would not directly
benefit from passage of this one way or
the other we do not have a consumer
product uh in the mix or planned to be
in the mix anytime in the next two years
so there's no I have no particular
disclosure or no particular conflict
with the passage of the solicitation or
I probably wouldn't have sponsored it
um but from a bit
one would hope
one would hope but at least from a
business perspective I can tell you from
Healthcare
businesses and people who are trying to
bring products into the market and make
it easy for payers and providers payers
and manufacturers
to encourage consumers to utilize their
products in their homes and you know
self-diagnose or get health care
information they all all those consumers
have to click on those end user
licensing agreements have to agree to
allow their health care data to be in
the cloud somewhere and they'll do it
more readily if they know they have
control of the data we want consumers to
be involved with their own health care
we want them to utilize the tools and
that goes for anything as simple as go
into the drugstore look at the tests
that you can buy the A1C test the STD
tests just go into a Rite Aid or a
Walgreens or a CVS ask them where the
home test kits are and you'll see Celiac
rheumatoid arthritis A1C you know for
your blood sugar you see them advertise
on TV Everly well is a big provider
any number of male male away kits Colo
guard you know if you're thinking about
getting a cool and they give you the you
know do it at a box and send it away you
have to sign you have to go in log in
register your kit there's a Eula
agreement you're agreeing to have your
data transferred people are reluctant to
do that because they're putting data
into the cloud if they knew they had a
way to control that data better they're
more likely to use those and people are
more likely to get those preventative
Diagnostics done and that's a good thing
for the world of healthcare so thank you
very much pass the Bill does anyone have
any questions representative
just just one question
um because the previous testimony we
heard that this pertains to services but
not to products and given the cue Health
that you mentioned my my aura ring is at
home charging you know a device that's
also a service does that
um does that
preclude that kind of Distinction or or
do you see it a workable divide funny
enough a product like the Q Health they
basically give you the device it's um in
Diagnostics they call it almost like a
reagent rental model they just give you
the hardware and you're buying a
subscription
uh for it and then
um you do pay for the consumable test
kit
so so there's a there is a there is a
service like they perform the so you pot
you buy the little consumable test kit
they give you I'm sure there's some
Capital costs that they build in because
I know the little test kits don't cost
you know as much as they charge you for
them and then there's a subscription
service so it's kind of both
that that makes sense so it's not
good Focus
oh I'm sorry more on
the
the bills
is it can you connect your question
to the bills before us yeah I'm sorry if
I wasn't clear I I was just trying to
determine whether this distinction
that's in the bill between goods versus
Services is something that will become
unworkable going forward so the the data
service so let me try to clarify um
they house your data and they these
diagnostic
um providers that it's all speak to
Diagnostics specifically you know lab
lab tests home health kits any of those
and there's just hundreds and hundreds
of them from cholesterol tests to all
kinds of things you know from Little
Finger sticks smeared on on a card send
it away get your cholesterol Celiac all
those things they house that data
they'll send it to your provider they'll
track it they'll advise you and many
times the key the the Big Money Maker
for them is not that you paid 50 bucks
or 150 or 199 dollars to see if you may
be on the Celia Spectrum right so you
shouldn't eat wheat it's really that
they want to sell that data to all the
people that sell drugs that can help you
or all the people that sell insulin if
your A1C is high so the real key to them
is the data monetization
right
so for you to have control of that in
some fashion you may agree that you'll
have
you you'll limit the resale of your data
limit
some of it right but it'd be nice to
have complete control of that
you'd be more apt to find like say what
I would personally feel better to know
what my A1C is let them share with my
doctor but not let them share it with
the entire world of world of big Pharma
or or every insurance underwriter
see where I'm going with that
yeah so so you don't think that having a
product tied to the collection of that
data leaves a big this leaves a loophole
for people to get around this but
because they could say well it's not a
surface it's the good that I that I sold
to you I I guess I don't know for sure
and if there's a loophole maybe we
addressed and we see it uh indirectly in
some of our use
um
on our computers where you have to
consciously agree
to how the data is going to be used I I
do believe the MDR does that the device
regulations in Europe does address it
differently yeah and and more
stringently uh for instance uh you can't
email people you can't even so much as
email direct email marketing in Europe
for medical devices and things so yeah
they're a bit more stringent
unfortunately our country has not done
that and so for those of us who refuse
to participate in
all this Corruption of our society
we have limited access as a result uh
any other questions
thank you very much for taking the time
sorry we missed you before and glad
you're here now
um who else and I see the municipal
Association
good morning
good morning thank you madam chair for
allowing me to comment today in h
queries with the municipal Association I
did uh send a rather lengthy letter to
the committee last week
um that our subcommittee last week that
hopefully you all received I'm not going
to go into great detail there I'm
certainly happy to answer any questions
anyone may have about that
um I want to thank you for the
opportunity to come in after you've all
discussed this because I think I better
understand maybe where the the
committee's going here
I certainly agree with um
with you madam chair uh with this the
DMV example that you gave earlier that
packaging that information together and
reselling it doesn't seem like something
that government should do and I I don't
think we have any
objection to prohibitions of of
government doing that
um just one note on that point is
you may want to make sure that
information held by the government that
could be obtained in other ways such as
through a right to no law example is
also
um it that's also clear that there's a
harmonization between kind of this
expectation of privacy that you're
working on along with
um the protections already in 91a
um as far as
um I guess just a brief summary of some
of the issues we raised and I did talk
with representative erf uh back in
January and February about this
um and we had some really good and I
think productive conversations
um we would like to see in House Bill
314 some clarification of the the
definition of third-party providers
I note my letter that some of those
um listed providers utilities really are
government owned or interact pretty
extensively with the government there's
some Provisions in our law about exactly
how that
um you know non-paid payment of water
for example bills would be collected
through your local tax collector we just
want to make sure that that
really goes to our core point which is
we want to ensure that government
continues to function
that's really what we want to see happen
um and we were also hoping that there
could be clarification on
um what the prohibition on government
was that's uh that that
Roman numeral two that has been
discussed extensively
um just to ensure that it's clear that
we're talking about information that's
not publicly available I think that
really just goes to some of the
committee's discussion about the
structure of the bill might be a little
confusing for those who are not uh
well versed in in in the law which may
be the case for many
um of the volunteers running local
government
um and we just want to make sure that
when they read it they understand what
they're supposed to and not supposed to
do
um and I guess the last point is that
um has been discussed briefly here today
but
um I think that there has to be some
sort of
um
in intent or or a skincare element for
the violation on the government's behalf
we don't want to see a situation where a
third party provider is providing has
decided to give the government
information
that either is beyond the scope of the
government's request or is
otherwise in violation of the chapter
that then results in the government
um
the government being liable for any sort
of violation certainly it's the case as
uh
as I believe Mr Kirk described you know
if we have a very specific
thing that the government is request
specific piece of information the
government is requesting
whether that's the reward or whether
that's through a subpoena or whether
that's simply just a request
and for whatever reason that third party
provider decides to hand over the entire
customer folder or file to the
government
um the mere fact that we receive that
isn't something that we think should
result in liability for the government
presumably whoever's in charge of that
case
um is going to properly dispose that
particularly if it's a criminal case
properly dispose of that in accordance
with existing
um evidentiary retention requirements
um at the conclusion of that case and we
don't want to give rise to some sort of
liability
that's obviously different than if the
case go then if the government goes out
with bad faith and requests information
they know is in violation of the chapter
so we think that's a distinction that
should be made
um just to clarify kind of where that
where that lies and that's really my
last three points in my letter
certainly happy to take any questions
anybody has
I don't think so and thank you very much
for sending that letter to us the
information
that comes in is helpful as we try to
figure out where we go from here thank
you
um anyone else here
well that's a surprise
okay thank you all very much so now we
have
had before us
um we have two bills
and chairman Lynn has articulated a very
strong and clear argument
uh of why he believes that the bills are
related to each other and might in fact
um
benefit from being combined
in order to avoid
um conflicts in
in each of them although we understand
that one has to
is dealing with the government and one
is dealing with private
um
Matthew could I make just one other
comment absolutely no I I do I do think
I I guess what I would say I do think
that it would
that there that we should at least
explore the possibility of combining the
two bills but the other point that that
I would that I would make is this
um my sense and I you know obviously
my sense may not be consistent with the
way the committee looks at it but
um my sense is
that 255
is
if not ready to go very close to being
ready to go I mean I could see a few
minor from my perspective a few minor
things that we might want to change and
uh uh I think some of them I I proposed
in amendments but I think that's very
very close to being ready to go 314 I
think has is you know probably has
uh much more work to be done and
although I think it should be I mean I
think it would be worth looking into
combining it with 255 I wouldn't want
I wouldn't want the
the
amount of work that might be necessary
to do that to
uh to sort of undercut the the
importance of 255 uh because I think for
even as a standalone bill that's very
worthwhile and and you know we we ought
to consider that that on its own if uh
it's it's not
if we were if we were gonna
um if if combining it with 314 would
mean that both of them did we didn't
move forward
let me just
um Talk for just a moment about uh
timelines uh
we have retained two bills
um we have
um I believe until
November 16th something like that to uh
vote on
on retained bills
um and we can do anything with those
retained bills we can uh that we can
ordinarily do with the bill we can vote
ought to pass as it is we can vote on to
pass with an amendment and we can vote
um an expedient to legislate and of
course we do have the last option which
I probably nobody wants which is uh
uh to keep for further study which would
be next summer we would look at this
again
um and so that we can do and in in
carrying that out we can keep the bills
separate or we could through the
amendment process combine them so that's
one part schedule the other thing to
keep in mind is that we have uh from
September 11th to 15th to file new
legislation if we uh were to decide that
if any individual were to decide that
that's the route they wanted to take and
then there is a third route and that is
as a a committee
I believe that I don't believe this has
changed perhaps since Grant could tell
me that we could
apply to the rules committee to ask for
permission for example to introduce a
new bill that did not conform with those
schedules I mentioned up until now so we
have a lot of flexibility
and we know we have the summer to do uh
to the extent that anyone is willing to
do the hard research that is necessary
we certainly know that although a number
of the people in the room
um did not volunteer to to speak uh
today that they have indicated to us
formally and informally that they are
available to help if we need additional
information or additional guidance and
um so we have those resources to work
with we that this committee would not
meet again until September and then
sometime between then and mid-november
the full committee would meet at the at
chairman Lynn's call
to vote on all our recommendations so
that's
I just want you to understand the the
time uh structure I did see
chairman Kirk raised his hand did you
want to add something could you please
go to the microphone because I know how
much you like this but these are all
um on video or whatever it is
uh thank you madam chairman when you
first called upon me I thought the
subject before the subcommittee was 314.
um
and it seems as though you're not taking
separate testimony on 255 but I do have
some comments on 255 if that is of
interest to the committee uh yes it is
we were we're interested in in testimony
on both
thank you
um
with your permission may I hand out
something to committee members of course
actually if I hand it out even without
um Senate Bill 255 as I understand it is
basically a
bill that has been promoted throughout
the country by Microsoft Corporation and
it's been adopted in several States I
think Connecticut is one of them
um
I'm not sure
or I'm not privy to why they're doing
this most large corporations
come in to oppose a state when it
proposes to regulate in a particular way
such as California has done because most
of these large corporations want uniform
regulation throughout the United States
and would prefer to have Congress
legislate and preempt States from taking
a different position
for reasons known to Microsoft they've
taken a different approach and they are
going around to various States I think
all of the states to try to have this
particular legislation passed
obviously Microsoft is a for-profit
business so in some way this bill is
important to their business model
but what that might be I don't know
I support the informational privacy
provision or aspect of this bill
but not its current form
it needs Amendment four of them in
particular
first
the way the bill is set up every company
that is subject to this bill
can have its own method for opting out
and its own procedures for opting out
as was alluded to before with the
exception of Representative Lynn most of
us are not going to take the time even
if we want to opt out to understand how
it's done in each of the different
companies because they will all have
different ways to do it how many clicks
will be required for us is unknown
so one of the things I would suggest is
that there be a uniform way for people
to opt out of the um
the use of their personal information
held by these companies so that it's
easy for us as human beings we have very
little time we don't read these long
descriptions it's hard for us to
understand how to go to column A or menu
a and then finally wind up on menu B and
then actually opt out
if you were to do that it would produce
a method at least that makes it possible
for people to take advantage of the
um
whether it's intended or not our lives
are too busy and too fast-paced for the
legislature to require all of us to go
through this process to opt out so an
amendment I think needs to be drafted to
simplify the process and make it uniform
that's the key thing uniform
secondly
and not as important as the first
this bill covers very few companies you
have to have at least a hundred thousand
New Hampshire subscribers before your
before these Provisions apply so most
companies in New Hampshire aren't going
to be affected this really applies to
larger National companies
I'm not sure
that that's fair
as consumers in New Hampshire why are we
saying that our information held by
national companies should be treated
differently from information held by New
Hampshire companies why shouldn't I have
the right to opt out from a smaller
company maybe just a New England company
or a unique New Hampshire company why
only from the national companies now you
can imagine why Microsoft has done this
it eliminates a lot of potential
opposition but for us as as consumers
the distinction is is not very clear
and I don't think it's a good
distinction
thirdly
um
this bill
is an opt-out bill whatever privacy
protections are in it you only get them
if you act if you don't act
you don't get them
I would suggest that if you're really
interested in protecting privacy that
you make this an opt-in
if you make this an opt-in
the first amendment is unnecessary
because all of the companies will do
their very best to make it absolutely as
what should be the default position how
do you want to protect privacy in New
Hampshire
do you want us do you want to make our
citizens work for it
then this bill does if you want to make
it
the default position you need to change
this from opt out to opt-in
finally
um
the enforcement Provisions in this bill
benefit the companies
number one there's no private right of
action
number two
it's only the AG who can enforce this
number three when he enforces it he has
to give the company 60 days notice if
the company corrects the problem within
60 days he can't bring the enforcement
um
if if I were in Microsoft I would think
that a passage of these bills would
enable me to
um
tell consumers that Microsoft is very
concerned about their privacy and has
done a lot to protect it when in fact
this bill does not really protect
privacy
opt-in is complicated sorry opt out is
complicated
and there's no enforcement so even if I
opt out and Microsoft chooses
um or some company like Microsoft
chooses not to honor this or in some way
makes a mistake I can't do anything
about it
but you know the AG is overworked and
understaffed so if you're going to pass
the bill as it is at least give the AG
the staff and the money uh to enforce
this
I appreciate your attention I'd be
pleased to answer any questions but
um
the problem with this bill is it
promises but doesn't deliver and
that really disturbs me if the
legislature were to go along with that
position
thank you madam chairman thank you
questions
uh thank you and thanks for that
testimony um focusing on the
um first sort of provision of an
amendment that you had suggested
um and and that resonates I think
because it is a very complicated world
and having to learn every company is
sorry this is so the question was do you
have a sense of how that uniform process
would be established by What entity
um and whether or not our passage of
something like that would
influence the way all these existing
companies are already operating
I wish I had the knowledge to answer
that question I don't I know there's a
problem I don't have a solution that's
just beyond me but there are people with
technical expertise who you should be
able to contact who can provide those
any other questions
no
uh thank you again very much for this
information I'm going to ask a question
again and I bet I'm going to have a
different answer this time is there
anyone in the audience who would like to
speak now
but just so I didn't forget it
in the back row uh thank you for the
opportunity
um my name is Curtis Barry I do
represent Microsoft and had not intended
to speak today but as they say in the
political debates since my client's name
was invoked I felt felt an obligation to
respond to some degree I'm not an expert
in the content of Senate Bill 255 to the
extent of How It's been developed over
the last several years and this have not
been involved with the stakeholders who
have done that from state to state but I
can respond to a number of things one
thing right off the bat to
representative Kirk's Enforcement issue
uh two points one is I don't think he's
had the opportunity to to know this in
the the budget and I think I sent this
all to you on an email
in the budget that was signed uh last
week by the governor the senate had
added Provisions to changes to House
Bill 2 in one change to House Bill one
that addresses the Attorney General's
enforcement concerns Doge changes
specifically are adding data privacy
enforcement to the laundry list of
obligations of the Consumer Protection
Bureau
the second is as the Attorney General's
representative at the public hearing
referenced they are funded by what they
call a settlement fund that's currently
in statute capped at five million
dollars the balance goes to the general
fund the Senate amendment that was
adopted increases that to six million
dollars so they have an extra million
dollars to to play with
and then in house bill one uh the Senate
added three positions and these were
changes that were worked on uh I hope
I'm not divulging any confidences but
between Senator
Rosenwald and a representative fairly
high up in the Department of Justice
they've added three positions a
paralegal and investigator and an
attorney specifically to address the
Enforcement issue the second point I'll
make about enforcement and it needs to
be reiterated is as Mr Harkins who
represent who works for Microsoft
testified at the hearing there is no
issue that has killed more bills privacy
related bills in this country
specifically this model than the right
of private action and if you look at the
chart that was referenced earlier you'll
see that the vast majority if not all
except California that have been enacted
do not have private right of action
I like to work on things I I like to say
I operate in the realm of the possible I
like to work on things that we can pass
and I do not have confidence that this
bill would pass with a private right of
action in in the language
so specifically
um back to some of the representative
Kirk's comments
um this is I would not characterize this
as a Microsoft bill I think if you look
at the Coalition of folks or folks that
have testified in favor of this both in
the Senate and the house in New
Hampshire and in other states there are
a lot of companies that that support
this bill
um
representative Kirk referenced his it's
if I understood him correctly uh his he
questions why
we would want to pursue legislation from
state to state because we want to seek
consistency and it should be dealt with
at the federal government that was Mr
Harkin's testimony we prefer Microsoft
prefers I'm sure a number of other
stakeholders do a federal solution that
is not forthcoming hasn't been
forthcoming thus like other issues
people who support this particularly
state legislators who
value privacy brought forth the
legislation on a state level
maybe that compels the federal
government to act maybe it doesn't I
don't know
um
so it's it is on the consistency from
state to state basis that people will
support this representative mcgu uh
cited that uh in as part of his own
support uh some of the stakeholders in
the private sector agree uh state by
state laws need to be as consistent or
uniform as possible to make it easy to
comply
but representative Kirk's proposed
amendments don't do that
in fact when you look at the chart and I
can give you some updates I made some
notes this morning since the hearing
Maine has introduced the bill that is
close to this model Delaware has
introduced the bill that's close to this
model and the states that have enacted
since the hearing include Montana Texas
Indiana Tennessee
I think as we indicated earlier these
are not all red States they're not all
blue States they're a good mix of red
and blue States because people across
the country value privacy on the part of
their consumer and I think the last
comment I'll make is I disagree that
this is ineffective because as I sit
here today I do not have rights over the
personal data that a private entity
company holds my personal data this bill
gives me rights so I'm happy to answer
questions of the best of my ability
thank you very much and miss um
Mr Berry um we have a form here
um
that the International Association of
privacy professionals last updated
619-23
but the the information you just gave us
differs a little bit in terms of I
believe unless I miss in terms of
laws signed to date
okay um so the iapp
um their website has two links that are
near each other on their website
somewhere under their resources
um
the one I'm referencing is the map which
and I again I believe I've sent both
links one is the chart that will compare
state by state what are the elements
that are similar you know the X's or the
check boxes
um there's also a map available
color-coded map uh that displays what's
which states where a bill has been
introduced which states where a bill is
crossed to the second body which states
where it's passed and which states where
it's been signed into law Etc a few
other changes for example New York and
Vermont had bills introduced I believe
but they're not currently active so the
their status has changed over over time
and what was this effect what were the
new states that you've added to states
where so yep um the states uh where it's
signed into law that I believe have were
since the public hearing on Senate Bill
255. our Montana Texas Tennessee and
Indiana
representative Andrews did you have a
question
did
yeah thank you madam chair I do have a
question
Mr Kirk's proposals the way I heard you
testify
I'm not really consistent with the laws
of the other states that they've passed
what if we did pass this how bad is it
going to be for the companies out there
I can't speak for you know all of the
entities and I wouldn't
answer on behalf of Microsoft to that
question until I asked them that
question
um but other than to say it would be
inconsistent
um and it's something that I've heard
for the last eight months or so working
on this model with with sponsors Etc in
stakeholders is that consistency is of
thank you for the question
anything else
thank you thank you for the opportunity
I'll ask once again is there anyone else
in the room who would like to share
um information with us all in
hopes that it's going to help us help
guide us as to how we're going to
proceed
I see no one else who is
interested so now it's back to us
um
where do you want to go from here
when would we take up some of like with
255 some of the small tweaks and things
like that that I some of which may be
big tweaks but
um when when do we take up the
discussions around those tweaks well as
a committee
um following house rules we may not meet
um
that does not mean that
conscious always of 91a that one or two
of us might you know
not work on uh avenues that we want to
pursue
and
by the same token again with less than a
qualm or individually we know that
people in the public who have views that
they will want to share can share that
with us we would not come together again
until sometime you know relatively early
in September but my hope would be that
when we came together in September we
would
um be able to bring to the table as
individuals
a much more developed view of where we
want to go
we have the the two threshold questions
do we
keep these bills
separate considering each of them but
considering them separately or is there
any any benefit
um in terms of
creating the best possible legislation
do we combine and that obviously is a
threshold question
um
and then we have the comments that have
been made uh informed comments that have
been made by a number of people
um
Municipal Association uh
Microsoft uh let current informal
legislators
um
and the members of the committee to help
inform us
uh what I don't want to have happen and
I have no control obviously is that we
say okay fine we've done this and now
let's put this all in the back of
the pile of things to do and we won't
look at it again as individuals until
September because these are complicated
issues and
um
I would think that
they do need some thoughtful
involvement
um
and one possibility is that as
individuals or perhaps as two of us
work on specific amendments that could
then
be reviewed by the committee and not
necessarily with the expectation that
they'll be accepted but with the
expectation that it gives us something
to focus on to decide where we want to
go from there or we might find that
someone has just the perfect suggestion
um
the timing is awkward I would rather
that we could say you know next week
let's get together again
um but
um for some reason I'm an office speaker
and so
um
but I do live by the rules so
that's my situation
um
chairman Lind oh first I see
representative Andrus has thank you
Madam chair sorry what I see here is
two great bills
for privacy
but I'm questioning in my mind
if we combine them would we try to make
them too complicated
it would be a complicated law
personally I think we should keep them
separated I do think they need to be
tweaked to both of them
and
make sure in the end
that we're not worried about
outside businesses I know they have to
be protected but I think our big thing
is the protection
of the citizen
because where I use a computer like I
get a lot of emails I don't I don't want
from companies and I just at the bottom
it says unsubscribe when it comes to
working with the company I just don't
know why it can't be that simple if you
don't want your information shared with
somebody and I just think we need to
work out things and I think it's going
to take a little time thank you
thank you if I I know so little about
all of this but if I could add one
comment
um if you got that initial initial email
as kind of a blind stab in the dark from
whomever sent it and you mark
unsubscribe what you have now done is
given them your email address
um
representative Alexander thank you madam
chair
um I
think that
um
I
I just go back and ask myself why
why is this bill being introduced it's
to create uniformity across
all states
but
what's stopping companies from doing
and I feel like
there's not a lot of
like incentive for us to even act on
this right now because there's nothing
stopping a company from doing these
things in here to begin with what
concerns me more is the citizens of New
Hampshire passed an amendment concerning
government entities nobody else
I think what we should
I I don't want to combine these but what
um I think Neil Kirk raised a lot of
um great concerns with 255 I
if I wasn't against it before I probably
am pretty I think there's a lot there's
some changes need to be made what I
looked at on here
um but I I do want to look at 314 a
little bit more
um
the biggest concern I have with 314 is
the enforcement
area of it I think that we can work on
some language there that would be
helpful for for me to get on board but
I I personally like I said before like
to start with government and start with
ourselves before we go anywhere else and
um you know I I have a sneaking
suspicion if
um 255 passes enough States and New
Hampshire doesn't act I have a feeling
that all those big companies will jump
on board anyways so thank you
thank you
yeah I would say after listening to the
details on the the two bills and and and
um the way that they
um protect privacy they seem fairly
different
um that the the uh 314 Bill basically
talks about the collection and and
keeping of data and whether when it's
allowed the other Bill sort of gives
consumers a lot of individual control
over a lot of aspects of
um uh the specifics of how they can
control that data what they can do with
individual pieces whether they can can
uh opt out of some things and not others
um so it seems more difficult
thinking in that way to
to combine them even though they both
sort of
address necessary pieces of the question
of of privacy collectively so you know I
do sort of think the I actually think
the 255 one probably is is further away
than
um than the 314 in terms of of because
there are it does seem like there's some
changes needed even just to make it
consistent with
um the way it's done in other states so
that would be my general thought right
now so my my understanding and tell me
if I'm wrong is that the point that
um representative Andrus presented to us
that they are
um they're separate bills and uh
that there's reason for them to be
separate bills
is that something that at the moment of
the understanding we're not committing
to anything now we're not voting on
anything that that would be
um the general consensus of of the group
um that they are
uh yeah sure I'm sorry representative
the only concern I have with 314 is if
there's any overlap
in 255 and if there's anything that
would would be you know contradictory
and just to double check and make sure
that there wouldn't be anything
contradictory say in 255 that would
oppose 3 14. and then the other thing
with two I think they should both be
separate but um on three on 255
um the idea of opting in as opposed to
opting out should be
um potentially researched I think
representative Lynn yeah I was going to
say I I have no problem with keeping
them separate the the with it with the
exception of the the very issue you just
raised on the on the on
um we need to be careful if we're going
to do that we just need to be careful
that we're not that they're
that we don't have we don't create sort
of a conflict between the two
um because
um for example 2 314 as originally
drafted without any without considering
any Amendment
um
would would appear to create
a an expectation of privacy and personal
information that may be different than
what 255 talks about or at least in the
at least the extent that it may apply
to
[Music]
um
to information held by
by uh private businesses for example
that are not covered by 255.
um
maybe that's a conflict maybe it isn't
but I all I think your point about just
being careful that we don't we don't
uh
I like to be a problem solver and I'm
feeling a little bit at sixes and sevens
now
um
I see that there are a lot of questions
before us that do need answers
um
let's see that the official structure
I think gets in our way
um
but I don't personally feel comfortable
asking
the speaker
if we could have
permission
to meet again
because there are a lot of reasons why
they do not have us here
including the fact that the staff needs
time to do all the work we haven't let
them do that they build people
responsible for the building need time
to make essential repairs and we all
need a cooling off period perhaps
um
and I just I guess my problem is I don't
want July and August to be dead time
yes representative Divine so the big the
big question for me now is if there was
a comparison between both bills to make
sure that they don't conflict how would
one go about doing that who do we reach
out to
um is there somebody already in place to
to look at that whoever drafted these
other bills
um and working together as though my
initial response to that is we have
identified
in each of the bills
areas where we might want to make
changes
nobody signed on the dotted line yet
so
to
to look at the existing language where
might not be the best way to handle it
in the timeline because we might want to
get a little closer to the final
language that we're considering
before we do that
and we do have a couple of months you
know in September and October
um I can well imagine that
representative Lynn has already
identified 16
uh 16 amendments that he's going to
propose some of which will incorporate
the first ten but um and I say that as
he knows with great admiration for his
commitment to this committee and to this
work
for that I appreciate very much
um but does anyone have any suggestion
to help me get past my feeling of
had best use time well could I make this
suggestion since and
since I'm as I've said before I'm
255 I'm
personally I'm kind of comfortable with
it the way it is and I understand that
there may be change you know people have
different views in it there may be
changes and that and you know and that's
fine
um
so so my preference would be and I and I
would volunteer to do this I I
um
would suggest that maybe I could work
with representative erf and uh
representative former representative
Kerr okay if they're willing over the
summer to try to make some changes
to 314
um that would
you know that would maybe be helpful to
address some of the issues that have
have been discussed and try to come back
um
to the committee in September with a
with uh proposed
with some proposed language some
proposed changes and I'm wondering if
somebody if those who have
greater concerns about 255 might be
willing to do the same
much for that is there
um
but is there someone who would like to I
mean I know you can get you'll get some
um I would be happy
um
to
take responsibility for looking at 255
and and
um now that I have done that I see two
others
um and let's see one Madam chair I don't
I don't want to take the lead but
there's too much on my plate but if one
two three four this six three
um I think three of us can can do it
because we're not a majority
um and so we can
and we're not going to vote
very good
um
and we will know that in in name on the
lead
um de facto
um okay anything else that we should
discuss right now
do people feel comfortable that we've
um if it's this were easy we wouldn't be
here we would have already acted
okay then I um
say that we are finished with our
subcommittee on 255 and
Senate Bill 255 and House Bill 214 and
we will meet again
as a full Committee in September
and thank you all very much for helping
the time is 1 20 and I'm going to go
ahead and open up the subcommittee work
session on House Bill free 62 Dash FN
which is an act relative to complaint
procedures and cases before the
commission for human rights
I do apologize for our delayed start we
went to the Human Rights Commission
office and we were a little bit delayed
in getting back
so I wanted to kind of open up
by giving a little bit of an overview in
what we just heard because rep Andrews
wasn't with us uh for that session so I
wanted her to have a little bit of
background and then I want to kind of
open it up if the committee has anything
to say and then if anybody else would
like to to speak
so
overall what we heard was that
um
the number of of cases I guess I can
give it over an overview of just
everything to start with the number of
cases that they currently have pending
right now is 230 cases and their oldest
case is
from February of 2022.
they currently have five investigators
and they did just receive budget to hire
four or more investigators
they get about 16 new cases per month
and the number of cases that they're
closing per year
averages around 225 cases so they are
getting through you know a pretty big
chunk of of cases
and
it seemed like the data that we got from
2022 the number of complainants that
removed cases to court was 30 38 cases
which was 12.8 percent of the overall
number of cases that had closed
the number that the respondent removed
was 22 cases which was 7.4 percent of
the overall
number of cases so
and then the number that was closed with
no probable cause was 34 and the
settlement percent was 24
and then the overall failure to locate
the party or failure to proceed or it
so it seemed like the number that are
actually being
removed to go to court isn't that high
anyhow but the most interesting piece
for me was hearing that in in the EOC
federally doesn't allow a responder to
move the K remove the case because they
consider it retaliatory
and New Hampshire and Rhode Island are
the only two of the 50 states who do
allow for a case for a respondent to
remove the case
that was kind of the data that we found
that I think is really kind of the most
important pieces because
I do think you know with their increase
in staff and whatnot that they are
making Headway into their significant
backlog which I think was part of the
reason why we initially wanted to do the
subcommittee session was to make sure
that
was the overall arching problem of
the committee being so backlogged being
addressed and it seems like with the new
budget and the fact that they are having
so many new hires in addition to the
four new investigators they're also
switching over three employees from
part-time to full-time including a
secretary a paralegal and the office
manager will be switching from part-time
to full-time and they'll also be adding
a part-time intake coordinator so with
that said I'd like to open it up to the
committee if you guys have anything else
rep Corrigan
um
one thing is the number that go to
number of cases it goes to a public
hearing
before the uh Human Rights Commission
they have seven Commissioners and three
sit on a panel is very small
that's about I think there's just been
three this year so apparently that's
partially by Design they encourage uh
the currency respondent they complained
and responded to subtle uh settle on
their own whenever possible and that's
the most common outcome and followed by
uh followed by
followed by you know
using sending it through federal or
Superior Court and also um even a large
percentage of them are found no probable
cause but that doesn't necessarily mean
the case was frivolous sometimes the
worker has a
it's a legitimately bad work situation
that's not purely the that's where
there's faults on both sides but it
doesn't go far within the rubric of the
employment employment law that is like
most of what commission deals with other
other issues whether it's like
actually I don't know the exact
percentage here but it's it's primarily
employment law that they deal with they
also deal with housing and public
education and public accommodations and
also there's a new uh pregnancy Fairness
Act they came in just uh the last year
so it seemed I mean it
of course they're the ones between the
it didn't it didn't seem to be a
organization in crisis so it seems to be
uh going well and they are they are
expanding so
thank you does anybody else
thank you madam chair
um I would recommend going forward
recommend to the committee going forward
with the legislation to propose
legislation and go getting that done
um
as far as the human rights commission's
performance
um I would like to
wait until we have the performance audit
to make an assessment
um I don't feel it's our place to
micromanage the Human Rights Commission
so I I just feel like you know they've
given us they've shown us what they're
doing it looks reasonable it looks fine
but let's get the um performance audit
done thank you
thank you rep Delorenzo rep Anders did
you have any questions because you
weren't able to actually be there um I'm
not sure if kind of the overview and one
number that I I had missed on giving out
was five percent of the cases are also
closed because of no jurisdiction just
to kind of add up I was just going
through to make sure my numbers added up
to 100 do you have any uh questions
about
thank you not really I mean my main
concern is and I think the performance
audit might help us and where they're
going to hire more people is to make a
quicker process
for the claimant because waiting two or
three years to get an answer is not
acceptable I don't get what anybody says
and we the process has to speed up but I
think what we have to do where they're
going to hire more and they have more
money we have to give them a chance to
see what happens thank you
I completely agree with that and that
was you know one of my biggest reasons
for wanting to retain the bill was that
it seemed like the the cases were taking
so long but after going in and hearing
kind of what they were doing and the
fact that they did get the budget to
essentially almost double their staff
and I think we need to see where where
things kind of go from there before
adding in any new legislative or
statutory changes that might try and
make it expedite things because we don't
want to have any unintended consequences
with that and
I didn't really see any areas that you
know once
if it seemed like if there actually was
Staffing available there would be no
reason why the cases could not be closed
within even a six-month time frame
so I do think once the backlog of cases
is caught up that we will be seeing a
much better turnaround
and
I
am not sure that there's any other
additional changes that necessarily
needed to be made I did think it was
definitely a very interesting piece that
were one of only two states who do allow
the respondent to remove it so for me
I'm kind of in agreement with rep
dularenzo that
the original bill that was in here you
know seems like it would make sense but
I would like to hear from those who are
before us
Rhett McLean you were part of the
original study committee would you do
you you've pretty much covered the
ground that we did in in the committee
last year this is verbatim language uh
from SB 296 which came to us last year
and this was total bipartisan
legislation
um with support from both sides
um and I think I would like to see this
go forward with the original language we
held it over last year again for some of
the same concerns while we thought yet
legally everything is right the U.S
Supreme Court says the claimant gets to
choose the Forum and you you talked as
well about the EOC
um and the fact that we were only one of
two states so we said yeah we think it
makes sense but at that time we were
hearing horror stories and we says if we
if we take away the right of removal by
the respondent is that just gonna Crush
um something that is already burdened
and
um we had a much harder time getting
data you apparently were able to get
lots of great data out of them
um but we had a very hard time getting
data but ultimately we came to the same
place that you're at they're they're
looking at taking in at that time it was
say 20 25 cases now you're saying it's
down to 16 and the data that we had was
the rate of removal wasn't as much we
were I think talking about maybe 10
cases removed but even at 22 cases is
being removed by the respondent it's
um a percentage that I think the Human
Rights Commission can absorb So based on
that
um I don't want to micromanage
um they're they're able to fulfill uh
the language that that is you know
required in the bill and with the
budgetary editions that have been
ongoing it sounds like they're able to
kind of bust that pimple
um much more effectively so I I think
all things being even uh that's you know
because I think I think it's just a it's
just a question of fairness as far as
that goes there is a performance audit
that we did petition the lpaoc for last
year which looks like it's going to go
forward which I think would give even
more data and and you know maybe
highlight other opportunities but I
don't know that this is something that
the subcommittee can really do I did
quickly look over
um the amendment from representative
Lynn which is kind of allowing
um for the respondent to remove
um
after the uh the the the the claimant
does
um so that would be if the claim is
allowed to remove after 180 days this
would give
um if I read it correctly the respondent
the right to remove about within 60 days
after that but I think that gets back
into the problem of you're allowing
either party to choose the Forum and
really
um
the the burden of proof is on the
claimant and so they get to choose the
form it's not equal with respect to
choosing the Forum and so I I don't
really have anything to say based on all
the research you've done other than that
I would like to see it go forward with
I have a question for you okay
um I just wanted to clarify the
information we were provided about the
EEOC and what what it is that they re
that they view as being retaliatory
having a respondent have the ability to
remove a case
without the claimant also having the
similar ability no the claimant can have
the ability because they have the burden
of proof it's it's I think the idea
behind it was that they want to prevent
discrimination right and the thought is
that a company may have the resources to
go to court and whatnot but
an employee may not necessarily have
those same resources to actually be able
to to rise to the level of filing in
court and hiring an attorney and all
that so the the idea of the respondent
being able to then take them over to
court and then they'd be you know Pro Se
over in court
was kind of seen as the this human
rights is supposed to be providing them
I guess financially reasonable within
their means that a lay person could be
able to enter in
a case to them but a layperson may not
necessarily know what to do if something
was sent over to the court
did you have something rip dealerenzo
yes thank you madam chair and um
representative
um Manos
um I I believe that one of the reasons
that
there was concern one of the things that
they were concerned about you know as a
committee was that with a respondent
only having the um
the right
to
move the case to Superior Court the
issue is that there's this backlog of
superior court that we know about and
doing so the respondent could do it like
remove it like at the last minute
um and that would delay the whole the
whole process so that's one of the
things but I think that with this
amendment it's almost like a seesaw
effect like we're saying that the
complainant would have the um the right
to to remove it too Superior Court but
then after 60 days the
respondent would have the right to
remove it so it's almost like you know
like a seesaw and it would be an I think
it would be on balance
oh Madam chair
yes so I think the reason that the
respondent has that
sorry the claimant has that right at the
180 days is because everybody has to
file at the Human Rights Commission you
have no choice so if it's if it's this
kind of a case that you're bringing
um that that has to do with being a
member of a protective class you have no
choice but to go and start at the Human
Rights Commission and so for many people
where there's a huge amount of
complexity to the case
um they may choose to retain counsel
but they cannot leave until the 180 days
is done
because they have to file there first
and the only and the reason that
that the EEOC and others have really not
been happy about this and view it as
being retaliatory is because it's not
that you have a finding of probable
cause and then the respondent removes it
as an appeal
they remove it and it's a noble hearing
so it wipes out everything that came
before so I put
um a news article from Union Leader
which Marissa Chase sent over to me I
think half a year ago which talked about
a case it's it's a it's an example of
how this is used so a gentleman at
Market Basket he took a a complaint to
the Human Rights Commission because he
felt he was not being given a full-time
opportunity at Market Basket and they he
claimed that they said look we reserved
those for younger people and so it went
to the Human Rights Commission and the
Human Rights Commission after two years
and seven months said yes indeed we find
that this is what we're finding in in
favor of the claimant at which time
Market Basket removed it to the superior
court and but not as an appeal but as a
de novo hearing so it was removed
without prejudice and basically
everything starts again from the very
beginning and I think that is why the
EEOC and the U.S Supreme Court viewed it
as being retaliatory and I think that's
why only two states allow it
thank you
and I want to thank representative
McLean for all of his work you know over
the work sessions
um last summer and continuously up to
this point he's been really fabulous he
dug in and um wrapped his arms around it
and that's we have
a bill to Bass thank you thank you very
much
would anybody who's in the audience I
thank you madam chair members of the
subcommittee for the record my name is
Dave jube I'm a senior vice president
for public policy with the business and
industry Association and you'll recall
from the hearing that we testified in
opposition to this bill and had a number
of attorneys that also testified
um opposing the bill and they have both
experience representing both claimants
and respondents before the Human Rights
Commission and they had experience in
cases before the EEOC I guess my request
at this point is to
delay a decision on this until the fall
and I'm asking that for a couple of
different reasons
one in the fall we should have the
performance audit I believe that can be
completed in the fall and we'll be able
to see what that report says we'll also
have
three or four months experience with
increased staff at the Human Rights
Commission and we can assess what type
of uh
hopefully positive impact that is having
on the more rapid adjudication of cases
but I'd also like you to hear
again from the attorneys that were
present that have experience because I'm
couldn't I just want to make sure that
all the information you're receiving
about the EEOC and how other states deal
with this this issue is completely
accurate
it could be I'm not an attorney and I
don't have experience with this issue
from other states
but
moving your decision making until the
fall which won't impact
how this gets reported out from the
committee next session would allow these
attorneys to come back in and answer
questions from the committee they'd be
here now except we're in the middle of
summer one is in somewhere in Italy one
is somewhere in California in the third
I just couldn't get to respond to my
email so I'm not sure what her status is
but I know the summertime people scatter
and so
we understand you'll make a decision
eventually it may not be what the Bia
would prefer but that's how things go in
the legislature but I would at least
like to make sure your decision is based
on the most current and inaccurate
understanding of this issue as it
applies in New Hampshire and also around
the country and also with the EEOC so
that's my request
so whatever we decide here today is just
as a subcommittee kind of our finding
but the entire committee the body of 20
would still have to to vote on what they
wanted to do with the bill before it
went on to the house to move forward
my only thing is I think we had
originally opened this up because we
were very concerned about performance
and whatnot but it seems like
some of the concerns
have been addressed and I think that
that's something if the audit committee
were to find something another bill
could be certainly opened up to address
something related to that but I'm not
sure that it would change
how we would proceed with this and I
don't I I hate to put you on the spot uh
would you be able to look for us and see
if that is accurate information about
the EEOC and US kind of being
one of two states that that only allow
that is that something I don't know if
okay
it
okay and if I could respond
I've been doing this for a long time in
the recommendation from this
subcommittee
will be critical in how the full
committee looks on this issue
and so it's important to me that the
subcommittee has all the information
available so that they can make the
right decision and what they believe is
the right thing to do on this bill so
again I would ask
I would ask that you resist the
temptation to make a decision today and
if you could come back as a subcommittee
in the early fall in in hold
not a public hearing but a work session
to allow some more input that would
still give
the full committee plenty of time to
hear your recommendation and consider it
before the reporting deadline comes up
okay we'll definitely take that under
consideration
um
thank you for for taking the time to
do you mind just repeating that in the
mic Sam while she hands those out just
so that those listening know
absolutely
oh can you say that one more time
we have Marissa Chase here the executive
director of the New Hampshire
Association for justice I'm Samantha
hearing I am a board member of the New
Hampshire Association for justice and an
attorney at Douglas Leonard and Garvey
so what I just passed around today and
thank you all for taking the time I know
this is representative Delorenzo and my
second summer in a row getting to talk
about all this
um I learned a lot today at the Human
Rights Commission this is a complicated
issue
and that's kind of always been our
struggle as our organization that wanted
to pass Senate Bill 296 and then House
Bill 362 is
for us it's a really simple little thing
I mean we have data from the New
Hampshire commission for human rights
which is in your packet
um in response to a 91a request of
October 5th 2021 that shows
when a response a respondent removal
versus
um
post a probable cause finding which is
again the standard of there could
potentially be discrimination here right
it's not supposed to be you know
adjudication judge jury
um let's see in 2015 there were 13
that's high we heard today for 2022
there were 22 cases but on average
2016 the respondent removed its sick
removed six cases after a probable cause
finding to Superior Court 2017 1 2018 7
2019 7 2023 2021.5
this is not a large number of cases that
are being removed by respondents to
Superior Court where a claimant then has
to start all over again and more likely
than not hire an attorney or not pursue
their case
but to those people it matters a great
deal to those people that have to start
the Human Rights Commission that go
through that whole process for years
waiting a decision and then to have a
game start over
that affects them
so while you know we got into these
other issues of peeking under the hood
at the Human Rights Commission why
things are taking so long because of
concerns that you all heard in testimony
from you know both lawyers on both sides
of the employment scale
um
you know the resource allocation
I'm glad that that is all moving along
and I thank you all for increasing their
resources for the Human Rights
Commission in the budget and so glad for
representative McLean's advocacy and the
performance audit review I think that'll
be fascinating I think that will inform
as representative qatab said other
potential policy decisions
doesn't really impact five cases a year
you know as we saw today the Human
Rights Commission can absorb about five
cases a year it could absorb 22 cases a
year
um that really doesn't have anything to
do with delaying this to see how more
investigators are working out or more or
what the performance audit review says
I see them as very separate and this is
something that um the simple fairness
issue not a resource allocation issue
I would Echo essentially everything that
Marissa just said I would also add on a
little bit those few cases a year that
are being removed by respondents to
Superior Court after probable cause
finding it looks like this for employees
they are a waitress or a busboy or a
Target employee making minimum wage and
they are sexually harassed they complain
instead they get fired so they pursue a
charge at the Human Rights Commission
they have very low wages maybe they've
only lost you know a total of 750 by the
time they find an attorney
when they call me and ask if I can
represent them in court I'm
unfortunately going to have to say no
because I am paid on a contingency fee
basis because employees like that cannot
afford to pay hourly I can't afford to
work for three for free because I have
to keep the lights on and so I do a
contingency which means whatever I get
for you I take a percentage of at the
end but I defer all of my compensation
until the very end
the compensation is determined by lost
wages
which means there's no money for me to
to be paid for my time at the end so
people like that will not be able to get
an attorney they'll have to navigate a
complex court system and litigation on
their own and most people are just not
equipped for that
um I would just briefly notice well that
you know we've heard from attorneys who
oppose the bill
um on a variety of occasions and one
recurring theme that I keep hearing is
what about the employer's right to a
jury trial there is no right there is no
constitutional right to a jury trial the
only for the employer for the employer
yes the only constitutional right to a
jury trial that exists are those rights
that were in existence at the time our
state constitution was passed in I
believe 1794.
um
and 354a didn't come into existence
until the 60s so that's that's not an
issue here and representative McLean
covered it well so I won't cover here
long but the choice of forum belongs to
the person who Bears the burden of proof
that is a principle of law that runs
through our our state system and
federally
um
and I would also
welcome data on whether or not it is
correct the New Hampshire and Rhode
Island are the only states that allow
the respondent to remove New England
states the only New England states
excuse me
um
it Bears noting how it how respondent
removal even got into our statute my
understanding is that when 354a was
being passed we were looking to a
constitutional challenge that was
ongoing in Massachusetts and we were
nervous about somebody raising a similar
constitutional challenge here and so we
put the respondent right of removal into
the bill essentially as a peace offering
to get it passed to move on
Massachusetts it never even made it into
their bill it never the respondent
didn't end up having a right to remove
over there so it ended up being a
non-issue
um
and to the extent that the EEOC May view
a respondent's right to remove as
retaliatory I have to say I agree and
that's why I've been here at every
session that I've been able to to come
to and sit in front of you folks
um
there is no legitimate reason for the
respondent to remove to court none
I can't stress that enough I can't even
come up with a hypothetical reason that
would be legitimate
um
and so with all of that said I think
that's all I have for now happy to field
any questions
if anybody on the committee have any
questions for uh
for for either Mrs Miss Chase or or Miss
hard
um attorney choice I wanted to ask it
doesn't really matter whether
um
New Hampshire and Rhode Island are the
only two New England states because if
if the EEOC views removal as retaliation
that's a national policy so I'm just
curious about
why you would be curious about what
other states allow respondent removal
um
just for the sake of
always telling the truth that's it I
just wanted to clarify the truth for the
record speaking of which I am not an
attorney but I work for them but thank
you
um
no I just I and again that was not a
fact we brought up that was what Sarah
Burke Holland um at the Human Rights
Commission said and I just wanted to
make sure that nobody was operating
under any false assumption but I totally
agree with you it doesn't matter if we
are
1049 or one of two if the EOC views it
as retaliatory
and we would agree
does anybody else on the committee have
thank you
appreciate it so I guess what I'd like
to hear is
where is everybody at I don't mean I
don't
I don't personally seeing my position on
this changing but I'm happy to you know
if there's no harm in us coming back in
September and just doing another quick
session just to to vote on it but I'd
like to just where's it where's
everybody's kind of head at with this
with everybody how does everybody else
feel
I mean that's I mean that's my feeling
we don't need to make any decision
decision today I mean the uh
I mean they gave a good accounting
themselves as a institution seems to be
functioning more or less as intended
although it is they are
expanding their staff which will make
them get to the cases quicker and uh
it's a
and they do go to Great Lengths to try
to uh the immediate mediation
in early steps in process have concealed
they can also have a conciliation which
is forced mediation before so
and as I said the number we did hear
about the low number of public hearings
pretend that that's basically kind of
the way
the process was designed to work the uh
thank you
thank you madam chair
as far as making a decision today
I don't feel we have to because the
hearing I was in this morning
they're saying we didn't have to do
anything until
September October because it won't come
up until November so we have plenty of
time and I would really like to see what
the audit brings us
and see if we can get some information
another couple of months it's just how
fast
the commission is coming forward with
these cases
so that see it makes a difference
I agree with that and actually just
reflecting kind of on what you mentioned
I guess I would say that typically that
the period to enter in a new LSR is
September but if there's a subcommittee
then the subcommittee kind of has until
November to make a decision and so for
that reason if something did come out of
the legislative Autumn that was I guess
after September but before November then
we would kind of have that period where
we could potentially put something else
in if needed so if
I guess if everybody's okay with that we
could you know reconvene you know in
September and kind of see where
everybody's at is that okay with your
reptiles right thank you yeah I'm I'm
fine with that
all right well thank you all for for
coming out I really appreciate it and we
look forward to meeting again in
September
I'm gonna close the hearing it is now 1